auf und davon spezial wird ihnen
präsentiert von kinder schokolade
vor fünf jahren sind der daniel schafer
und carolin schneider abruf schwede
ihren traum mehr freiheit für sich und
ihre schlitten
oben in lappland einer ferienanlage und
mit erfolg auf vordermann gebracht
einziger wermutstropfen der wildnis mit
ihrem geschäftspartner of guys großen
projekt ausstieg nicht
die hip hop sure trifft ihre frisch
bachem familien caroline und daniel sind
völlig überraschend ältere wurden 1100
[Musik]
menschen einhufer thrifty ehemalige
geschäftspartner roll verfahren frau und
kind leben immer blieb
[Musik]
viele auszug des siegers
so nur in schweden das ist bei zone 20
stunden am tag scheint
ich bin unterwegs zu der carolin
schneider und daniel schafer sie wohnen
in polargebieten archiv im dorf blatt
mixa
in schwedisch lappland führe zu ferien
[Musik]
es ist fast zehn yamaha big aber
caroline und daniel hug seitlich wir
sportlich hoch saisonsieges ständig auf
dabei und außerdem gibt es da ein china
politik wo sich noch überhaupt nötig
halte
sehr stur gebiete rezession vorbei sei
wir sehen also erst wieder und wieder
stark von der bei der itc fünf jahre
zurück
im schwarzenberger landkarte
schon in der schweiz lebten carolin
schneider und daniel schaffer
abgeschieden wegen der hunde
nun steht die ausweitung an eine
viertägige fahrt erwartet die tiere 19
schlittenhunde werden eingeladen die
hälfte davon gehört rolf kaiser der mit
frau silvia und tochter lena mit
auswandert wird der ausgebildete koch
ist geschäftspartner von daniel und
karoline
im oktober 2011 heißt es adieu
[Musik]
ein schwerer abschied auch für den
ehemaligen polizisten daniel
[Musik]
knapp 3000 kilometer weg liegen vor
ihnen
ihr ziel eine selbstbestimmte arbeit
ohne chef und viel freiheit für sich und
ihre runde
als sie ohne zwischenfälle endlich bei
der ferienanlage sun garden ankommen
herrscht große erleichterung und tiefe
müdigkeit
[Musik]
die auswanderer übernehmen die anlage in
laufendem betrieb
die ehemalige pr fachfrau caroline
beantwortet das allererste telefon keine
talkshow barriere die jahr heißt eben
sehr gut
die cracker mit weniger sagt eva lange
staus 138 bedanken sie zeigen das
problem konnte im todesfall somit
sicherlich nicht morgen wieder
mitmischen möchte ich hab mich einfach
auf das wäre irgendwie ihr eines
problems das älter wirst du die nicht
dicker bald ein freudiges ereignis
nachwuchs bei den schlittenhunden die
welpen wachsen schnell ein paar monate
später ist gar nahezu fertig mit der
herrschaftlichen zwingeranlage für seine
runde
die kalte jahreszeit zeigt sich in ihrer
ganzen pracht
polarlichter sind am himmel zu sehen
[Musik]
von bronze bis 4
der sommer zieht ein
und trotzdem eine eisige stimmung bleibt
caroline und daniel haben sich mit ihrem
mit auswanderer rolf verkracht
danke witze wenn es abschiedsvorstellung
dann chris schmidt bestreitet stebel
krieg große fertig werden wird der
verbringen holz arbeitet schon eine
weile als koch in einem hotel
bald wird er den sand schulgarten nun
ganz verlassen denis makarov was für
seine die rechtliche situation ist ja
bald wohnsituationen aus und im moment
ist natürlich erschöpft von
altfahrzeugen schokoriegel sozialisiert
überhaupt was bedeutet sie hätten
unterschiedliche ansichten entwickelt
sagen die beiden genaueres wollen sie
nicht ausführen
doch offenbar sind die differenzen tief
[Musik]
rolf packt seine hunde ein und verlässt
den sand schulgarten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was im mantel greif richtig in spa nicht
vor der situation muss torischen uwe
dass das einfach irgendwie die spanisch
war die ganze zeit für träume vieler
bürger fall muss ihnen der hand
rolf bezieht die der umgebung ein haus
mit seiner frau silvia und tochter lena
carolin und daniel führen den sancho
garten nun alleine weiter wirken
die anlage ist ganzjährig geöffnet
während der ruhigen winter saison haben
sie jedoch deutlich mehr zeit für ihre
schlittenhunde und für die zweisamkeit
es ist ein harziger kopf hochkriegen auf
der bettkante und und london über und
bisher auch so graue nach einer fragte
was ich nicht zahlen kann
also wird das ewp 10 uhr nachts hat es
ist also für mich das wirklich das
vertrauen das nicht an den haben
einander als auch für das ist schon
absolut
[Musik]
vier jahre sind sieht harris land zogen
kalte dunkle winter und sommer nicht
immer hellblond ich habe nun ganz andere
traum in erfüllung gegangen wo caroline
und daniel vorstufe das große glück
reißt joshua
[Musik]
anfangs 20 ist carolin schwer
nierenkrank wurde herzten kleid sie
können die branche noch nie als
kinderbuch ihre familie plant die beide
begraben und sich oft und arbeit
konzentriert bist gar mit 40 völlig
unerwartet schwanger wird
am anfang sind wir wirklich rückt das da
der schwangerschaftstest die mehrere
schwangerschaft extreme auf und hält den
moment dass dies nicht stimmt
sofort werden erste stimmen
also das sind überhaupt crystal sony
laut plant kein universe er ich glaube
dass das amsterdamer hand und und aber
die sauber beeinflussten im einem
alljährlich b sogar schweizer cup
eigentlich bin ich mit ihm also mit
politisch im notbetrieb prüfen
und hier setzt das plötzlich nach
und jetzt wird anders sie
aufwändige schild das kritisch beurteile
ich bin wirklich wirklich wirklich damit
fraglich
das ist nicht immer einfach wurzer meint
die beiden auswanderer quartett carolin
heißt jetzt auch schafe zum nachnamen
jetzt und ich geschichte von der galin
und daniel keine stunde benötigte sancho
gordon für die 2
die ferienanlage schlagen wenn es
gemeinsames baby für die bereitung
jetzt ist's richtig hinter zu euro in
der hochsaison oktober fast nur schweiz
viel familie
ich finde so forsch los und ja natürlich
abkürzung refinanzieren will ich
natürlich in exter und wahrscheinlich
über nacht unbedingt das wäre ich
natürlich sofort du schläfst du und du
schlafen auf der anderen seite und du
sehr gut aber mache der name ist oder
[Musik]
wie soll die schweiz einzig ali am 14
die haben ja selbst filmen kennt was
macht den user faszination das heißt es
du verstanden warum sie dann in andere
zu absolut ich sage die familie war
erreicht als ich ja schon schön aber ich
meine dass sie zum aber im winter ist so
weg vom schuss sich so einsam
das macht die extreme dass die extreme
temperatur im winter die jetzt auch die
die ganze fahren im sommer das ja
das fehlt mir die schweiz sich nun das
zu helfen wenn ihr das man hier quasi
auf der straße unterwegs ich glaube dass
das die schweiz
na ja das ist so dennoch entstand um
sich machen natürlich ein tag in der
woche hätte daniel als papa tag
reserviert das wissen natürlich sind die
ruhe finden außerhalb von ferien
da ist schnell der einzige weit und
breit gibt es da nicht gerade viel
ich kann mich nicht mehr und haben hier
siege für die hessen wo nicht ganz herr
natürlich wo hauptsächlich später e mail
kontakt
[Musik]
auf der restaurantterrasse nisch
hochbetrieb
yoopress die behörden langsam aus seinem
bis zum vatikan will endlich auch für
schweden zweimal mit schweizer außerdem
steht er absagen vereins wird sich nach
sichtung getränken swisscom und dafür
mir jedes mal fangen auslacht länger
vorbereitet mit dem nachfolger der
betrieb wurde ferienanlagen in team
möglich jetzt umso mehr aber obwohl sie
erst vor sechs wochen mutter geworden
ist schon sich caroline spezialität
dann haben wir die vorstellungen und
gewartet dass diese so umgesetzt wird
relativ lang sehr viel geduld wenn ich
merke dass es einfach nicht auch einfach
nur funktioniert nach einem stick
morgenroth wänden auseinanderbricht zu
dürfen
die woche zum 24
[Musik]
inzwischen zieht sind neu gaming geister
der thurgauer familie schlaf zweifach in
meiner zeit auf dem autodach aber wenn
es um krieg ort gibt's kein kompromiss
einschätze eigenkonstruktion ihr bein
unterstehen buch jetzt in den ferien ja
eigentlich je nachdem ob kaffee ist das
ein prototyp ausbaustufe gedacht war
auf den socken zu sagen sie seien sicher
dass die anderen besucher durch ok aber
das schaffe ich wieso also wird es war
wie hoch die kombination hatte
installieren so geht's jetzt macht ein
loch selber gelangen
[Gelächter]
dennoch kann der daniel ist retour vom
wagen und gott noch kurz über teil
versichert 22 5 v
die grönländer
euro
carolin heimat pro buchung ihres asien
buffet unter daniel simon aprilia durch
für den rest der woche einzeln
hochgestellt es sind viel schwerer in
uster umgebung und austausch sowohl
abwechslung zu den camping presleys
anderes grizzly der luft
aber was von jetzt mit den lappland
das war jetzt nicht sehr stunde mit ja
gut noch keine ferien ist ja mit premium
abgeben darunter markus hier oben
zukunft schon ein jahr später in pension
aha option dass ich durchgekommen er
hatte weckte große muckel sondern wie
viel ändert ja und was wenn der alarm
war um göttliche schönheit ist gar nicht
denn da wirklich nur für banken die hoch
konnte das bremsen
am 11 corzine 44 stunden und als ersatz
tauchte vollmundig
[Musik]
autor daniel mischt sich unter die gäste
und am nächsten morgen aber nur
feriengäste in der woche vom sancho
golden ich schon wieder betrieb die
beiden auswanderer machst morgen parat
bach ist ob man sieht das internet
schuld daran gibt frau glücklich ist
schon 62 stunden gesunken ist
während hoch sich zeigen
schierke schlaffördernd zuständig aber
habe ja sicherlich das 14 wochen soll
dann sind sie dann auf die europa trifft
ein normaler arbeitstag wird aber in
einem schloss am ende mit unterm strich
ist ja nicht mit mir den kofferraum
liegt werde mit irgend ein bisschen so
es regiert schafft sich ab das
funktioniert
das funktionierte was mir die
ausstellung natürlich auch heute wo es
natürlich hier ist ein klassiker
schlosser man klargestellt die zeit wird
caroline unter daniel ein riesenschreck
sie trösten und verantwortet wird
mitarbeiter sind ein die aber sehen da
muss er lernen los und delegiere weg der
geburt vor ihrem sohn joshua einst
schritt jetzt wähle und mühsam machen
^ ^ und du und deine waffe sinken
jahrhundert war und mit probierte das
wirkt für mich genau das thema und
tatsächlich oder was auch immer es ist
extrem schwierig da jetzt eigentlich gar
nicht groß integriert aber das geld an
gesund und schlussendlich ich glaube
dass sie schon nicht so schlimm
in diesem morgen zu jedem jugendlichen
hoch und sollte sich nicht machen konnte
oder bleibe was passiere zu groß wird
also
er mietet schorsch ua mit nur minimalen
zuwachs sind insgesamt sechs angestellte
hochsaison don bosco andere zins
ursprünglich als vierter mit dem hoch
rolf kaiser und seine frau silvia
das hat bekanntlich nicht gegen caroline
und daniel wendt fordert kamera nehmen
über die zeit retten abgeschlossene mit
und mittlerweile sogar finanziell alles
geregelt
doch der trainer kennt caroline unter
daniel beschlossen um rolf sind teil der
liegenschaft ab trafen auf der suche
nach finanziellen lösungen sehr
privatperson in der schweiz gefunden und
hälfte liegenschaft gekauft hat und sie
sieht er caroline und daniel ihre firma
verpachtet
natürlich im rudolf kaiser besuchen
rolf schaffen die man als koch im hotel
und wohnt nun mit 80 km weg vom sancho
gordon tochter lena ist noch stetig zu
monokini freut mich das werk sie folge
am schluss dem schweizerkreuz ja so ist
es mir geht's nicht los die ihre musik
und wegsehen wenn ich mir räume jetzt
einfach frech und zeigte immer wieder
hoch aus als könnten wenn die gamestar
kölners ganzes leben raus aus dem
südtirol fix aber die kalte jahreszeit
gesetz anders
der letzte winter ziemlich hart quartal
lag sie da ja was aber ist der trend
dass wir zurück also das ist wohl nicht
mehr bevorzugt muss waren vierter
fünfter sagt das 2 ich glaube dass jeder
muss im moment sieht europa als bier
trinkt oder so sagt wenn du musst
wandern und schloss bei skf passiert
er hat jetzt das nicht das ist wirklich
wenig wirklich geglaubt habe dass am
schluss erleichtert dass er ganz anderen
ganz allein ist rolf dein produkt immer
noch sind acht stück sind
sind natürlich liegen
wer wird nach praktischer letzten drei
stück verloren deshalb auch so kleine
ältere bestand eigentlich also das
jüngste mit bio ja das ja die letzte das
museum sagt er
mittlerweile sollte und ich muss sagen
es muss spezielle
die an dieser aus der schweiz mit
notiert sagt ja das ist jetzt die auf
die dauer ist natürlich im rolf
schweizer fahne immer noch prominenter
ruft kennt als die schwedische wenn du
die haie oder heimat denkt denkt schon
daran haben außerdem muss er für 14 tage
tritt extrem kurze auf miss schweiz nach
wie vor schönste und was geht da gebe
ich gar nicht traurig dass ich mit
graphics aber sehr viel und dass man
nicht verliert
das wird eher schlimmer
[Applaus]
ich konnte immer in der schweiz glauben
ich war jetzt länger zugänglich machen
aber ich persönlich bin ich
aber ich werde jetzt so bilanziert also
als ich aufs klo und rissen freie lockt
sie also für mich persönlich ist lohnt
einfach so einem in friedrich funder
ganz blöd aber wechselt wieder machen
oder die piste aber nicht möglich so
funktioniert das vorstellt ich hoffe das
ist ein kleiner gemacht ja schon
vorgemacht
ja das ist so etwas wie die formel 1
geändert aber auch nicht so schnell wo
sich know me 2 selbst ein funktioniert
hat das wesen nicht aber gut da hat das
ganze sicher nicht der bezirk das ist
also das gute sehr gut geht lena ja ich
gute möglichkeit sehr gut angenommen
[Musik]
nachdem zu achten auflage die
schwedische landschaft athletic spürt
man große freiheit aber umgekehrt haben
sich sicherer unendlich verloren fühlen
wenn sie gerade nicht so gut geht
dass willi noch es im treff verschrieb
mir rolf es gebe jetzt wieder eine frau
aus in rasierte
dem sohn jack gordon co 2 montags
hundeklos malamuten grünländer spüre die
immer schon vor russ 1 prozesse gibt für
die hunde das junge ja jetzt mit will
natürlich real ich ja eigentlich ein
bestens auf mehr oder weniger und freude
geführt das ist ja das kochen natürlich
hoch das ist eine frisch vielleicht im
moment gewinns fleisch das für die
mannschaft wurde jede fragen dann
eventuell mit im training in st wir
brauchen sie meine gibt es natürlich
auch mehr leisten
[Musik]
halo hat sie ist ein kommissionsmitglied
dem hier vor schwerer von günter perl
heim mit jeder hat ja ich wollte und ich
im prinzip der strom von sohn joshua es
ist das geburtstagsgeschenk sie sehr
stolz für ihn an sich also eher ein
letzte hund auf ihn über das macht mir
danke mehr bedient so unternahmen freude
dahin lebte fast zwangsläufig kann nicht
zwischen die stühle
[Gelächter]
aber die einen campus wichtiger
bestandteil was im lager
bis jetzt hatte wassersport dem motto
auge um das letzte wort steht oder was
auch immer sich natürlich sind
entschuldigt
das ist so aber die wege mit ihm groß
wurde bis jetzt nicht im gegenteil
so gibt es ein paar millimeter im stock
konnten sich aus dem dann das hört zu
nicht daran was geht's zur sache wo man
auf kein haus machen der chance doch ob
dieser mensch war
[Applaus]
diana ist vor streuen
wichtig ist am besten mit eltern habe
irgendwie so also nichts neues
kooperatives motto jeder harry habe und
eine innere sie zuvor war deutschland
mit gegangen daher würden sie mir
erzählen interessiert ist leichter und
das gibt mir einfach eine weile mit
einer
zone strahlt und strahlte beim
soundcheck worden
ich habe mir für mich glaubt gerade für
die schönste woche vom jahr ausgesucht
feriengäste sind alle unterwegs
es ist ruhig auf die ferien für den
moment
[Gelächter]
und zwar konnte so konzentriert wie der
mikrokosmos antigone verschleiß was
politisch gelernt was ich rasiere tvo
und horst sportjugend sowie software ag
aus münchen bereich persönliche
gesundheit
das ist so global sechs kriterium frühes
und wenn er gefragt und das aus mit mir
meter lang 45 zurück dass immer noch
plant die menschen damals plan gemacht
so wie sie braucht mit familie panik die
htg jungen große familie kaiser ab und
zwang sie und bin nach antworten statt
schwanger und die stadt rund platz und
schon erhält man realisiert es gibt
jetzt möglich die sand stecken scheiße
stillstand ist gleich rückschritt jetzt
heißt einfach ja die chancen ergriffen
wie sogar mein frühstück und ersparte
überraschung und das macht es nicht um
so mehr in sich blieb stoff machen
[Musik]
carolin und daniel
zuerst gemeinsam news corp und kunde 12
für ihre familie
merck stufe gold sucht der insel bali
sieben jahren führt an die kuren und der
orlando stammte aus hotel ohne sie live
mit
ich habe kontrahent genug ende jahr muss
das ja fix ist es werden krank oder mehr
wir möchten wirklich nimmer die beide
zur schweiz
[Musik]
wie der über das neue management habe
krumpöck mahnen seit 2003 wird die hand
nimmt
[Musik]
auf und davon spezial wurde ihnen
präsentiert von kinder schokolade